كان بإمكاني أن أتخيل حتى تعود الأبقار إلى
المنزل ما سأكون أولًا فيه وهذا
ليس مات مور لديه حس
الدعابة تمامًا ،
قصته فريدة بشكل لا يصدق ولكنها بعيدة كل البعد
عن كونها مضحكة
في سن 39 ، كان يعاني من قصور كامل في
القلب عندما  يأتي الناس إلى
الدوق ويبحثون عنا بسبب طبيب القلب
الدكتور آدم ديفور يقول إن الأوعية القلبية لمور
كانت مسدودة بشكل كبير
ولم يكن قلبه يحصل على ما يكفي من تدفق
الدم وقلبه أصبح ضعيفًا للغاية
وشعرت بالإرهاق وأنت تعلم أنك لم تشعر
بالراحة وهذا  كنت أعاني من مشكلة
في النوم في الليل ، كانت الأمور خطيرة للغاية ، حيث
أرسله أطباء مور لرؤية الخبراء في الدوق ،
لكن في غضون 24 ساعة ، أخذ منعطفًا
للأسوأ ، نعم ، لقد قام بترميزه بالكامل
، قال الطبيب إنني كنت
ميتًا في الغالب لمدة 45 دقيقة
أنهم
لم يتمكنوا من العثور
عليك تعرف نبضًا وأشياء من هذا القبيل
وكان الأمر كذلك ،
لكنهم أخبروني بعد ذلك أن
هناك فرقًا بين موت الدوق
والموت العادي لم يستسلموا
لك ، لم يفعلوا لم يفعلوا ذلك
وا  مريض جدًا لانتظار عملية زرع قلب ،
لذلك قرر جراحه
تجربة شيء جديد ،
لذلك عرف في الواقع أنه لا يزال قيد الدراسة من
قبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ، قال حسنًا ، قال حسنًا ،
هناك هذا الشيء
، وهكذا بدأ يطلق عليه
carmat أول قلب اصطناعي تمامًا
تم تطويره في أوروبا ، والخداع الوحيد
الذي تعرفه أننا كنا على ما يرام ،
إنه أول مريض في
أمريكا الشمالية
في المرتبة العشرين فقط في العالم ،
لكن المخاطرة كانت تستحق العناء بالنسبة لمور
وعائلته بما في ذلك المارشال البالغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات
والذين هم  تم تبنيها مؤخرًا ، فأنت
تعلم أن أكبر شيء بالنسبة لي هو
العودة إلى المنزل
لرؤية ابني ، لذلك قاتلت وحاربت
في يوليو ، حيث استبدل الجراحون قلب مور
بالقلب الاصطناعي ، حيث يستخدم قلب الكرمة
مضخات إلكترونية وأجهزة استشعار ، لكن
الدكتور ديفور يقول إنه مصنوع
خصيصًا لجسم الإنسان  الأجزاء التي
تتلامس مع الدم مصنوعة من
أنسجة الخنازير لأن المعادن أو غيرها من المواد
يمكن أن تتسبب في تجلط الدم البشري ، ونحن قلقون
بشأن الجلطات التي يمكن أن تنفصل
وتنتقل إلى أي مكان.  إن إثارة الدماغ تسبب
السكتات الدماغية ، فلنعد إلى المنزل حيث أن
القلب الاصطناعي أبقى على قيد الحياة لفترة كافية
ليصبح أقوى بينما كان ينتظر متبرعًا بشريًا
في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) ، أعطى فقدان عائلة أخرى
للمورز مزيدًا من الأمل
عندما تلقى أخيرًا قلبًا بشريًا
ساعدوني في الحفاظ عليه.  حياتي
وأنا ممتن أكثر
لذلك سأخبرهم شكرًا لك ، أنا آسف جدًا
ولكن شكرًا جزيلاً لك على كل
ما فعلته بينما يغادر المورز الدوق
يقولون إن معجزات الطب الحديث التي
تحدث هنا أعطت  لهم فرصة
أخرى للاعتزاز بكل لحظة مع ابنهم
ممتنًا لكل ثانية
وكل نبضة قلب أنقذت
حياتك أنها أنقذت حياتي تمامًا
ولا شك في ذلك